dulces
me dijo un amigo que para quitarme el
nervio de hablar en este foro que me
imaginara las personas en ropa interior
entonces le doy las gracias a todos los
que me hicieron favor de quitarse su
ropa para hacerme sentir mejor
muchas gracias se ven muy bonitos
quienes de ustedes creen que la
felicidad y el éxito pueden ir de la
mano que levanten la mano y digan yo
eso soy tony hash te voy a contar mi
historia personal y como logré hacer que
la felicidad y el éxito si fueran de la
mano en mi vida quizá te pueda servir
como guía quizá te puede servir como un
consejo para que tú también lo puedas
hacer te late ok
mi historia empieza en 1975 soy hijo
único de una familia de clase media-alta
y estoy con mi papá y con mi mamá y ese
bebé hermoso que parece de gerber soy yo
tuve una familia unos papás con unas
conductas intachable con unos valores
éticos morales personales me inculcaron
muy bonitos principios me dieron muy
bonita educación muy educado los dos muy
finas personas y mi vida transcurrió sin
ningún acontecimiento negativo que me
trago mara y fui muy cuidado del niño
muy querido por mis primos mis tíos y el
centro de atención de toda la familia
pero hubo tres cosas que aprendí de mis
papás en la crianza que ellos me dieron
que no me gustaron y que a la larga
cuando yo fuera adulto me causarían
problemas esas tres cosas que yo aprendí
de ellos que no me gustaron y que
después me causaron problemas fue la
primera la sobreprotección lo primero
que pues lo peor que puedes hacerle a
una persona que amas es sobre protegerla
resolverle la vida porque así pierden la
capacidad de resolver su propia vida de
sus propios conflictos mis papás me
resolvieron todo mi mamá me acuerdo yo
creo que todavía en la secundaria me
andaba ayudando a hacer la tarea
invitando a los maestros a comer para
que me pasaran de año no así exagerado
luego el sobre control mis papás eran
sobre controladores me decían cómo
vestir cómo hablar cómo pensar cómo
moverme como no moverme y me acuerdo que
future avant y me sentaban en la mesa en
las tardes y me decían hijo tú vas a
estudiar una carrera administrativa te
vas a casar después de los 30 años vas a
tener dos hijos un hombre y una mujer
vas a trabajar en una gran empresa y te
vas a jubilar y vas a vivir una vejez
digna con la pensión que trabajar el
seguro social no va así bien exagerado
así súper controladores y la tercera
idea o la tercera cosa que no me gustó
es que mis papás creían que la felicidad
del éxito no pueden ir de la mano mi
papá me decía hijo aquí se viene uno
y me decía si quieres ser feliz ve
por esas estupideces pero tienes que
entender que si eres feliz y buscas tu
felicidad vas a ser pobre o si quieres
ser rico vas a ser infeliz y esos tres
aprendizajes yo me los llevé a mi vida
adulta me gradué licenciado en
mercadotecnia y cuando quise empezar mi
vida laboral y profesional esas tres
cosas
como una pesada losa muy difícil de
llevar porque porque me sentía inútil yo
no tenía la capacidad de resolver mi
propia vida estaba acostumbrado que mis
papás lo hicieran por mí y le sacaba la
vuelta a los problemas los esquivaba me
escondía y cuando ya los tenía de frente
y que ya no les puede sacar la vuelta
mamá papá ayúdenme y me ayudaban todavía
porque estaban ahí entonces y me sentí
inútil en la otra era sobre el sobre
control y yo quería controlar cosas que
estaban fuera de mí quería controlar
personas quería controlar amistades
quería controlar mi pareja cuando me
daban chamba quería controlar los que me
dan chamba págame esto damm este puesto
y como no podía me frustraba pues ya
tenía lo inútil por la sobreprotección
lo frustrado por el sobre control y pues
en la tercera que era que la felicidad y
el éxito no pueden tener la mano me iba
por proyectos económicos o laborales y
perdía felicidad porque me sentía
prisionero y abandonado y tiraba todas
las chambas tiren muchas llamas para
buscar esa felicidad que tampoco llegó
porque no tenía dinero
entonces no tenía una no tenía la otra y
estaba tan hundido en mis problemas me
sentía inútil me sentía frustrado y
aparte me sentía infeliz y pobre
entonces perdí las ganas de vivir un día
entré en una depresión profunda debido a
eso estaba muy enojado con mis papás los
llegué a odiar con todo lo que se puede
odiar odie mi vida odie todo lo que
había a mi alrededor y un día decidí
terminar con esa vida entre una
depresión profunda que me dejó en cama
casi dos años como un vegetal entonces
me fui a un lugar que hay aquí cerca se
llama la cascada de san antonio tiene
una caída de 50 metros es una caída
libre esa es la cascada de san antonio
la explorer la fui a ver y dije por
donde me voy a tirar para que sea una
caída limpia y que me libere de todo ese
dolor que traigo mucho odio si mis papás
me paren las lance mis últimas
maldiciones a ellos a la vida adiós a mí
y de un paso hacia adelante
estoy vivo no soy un holograma
unos segundos después no sé cuántos
pasaron yo creo que perdí el
conocimiento abrir los ojos y estaba
cinco metros abajo de donde yo me había
tirado yo de cabeza y de esta pierna
atrapado por una rama que salía de la
grieta de la piedra 2 me asusté mucho
dije a la madre no me quiero morir dije
me asusté mucho y empecé con una
adrenalina y algo y para arriba me
gustaba escalar y pude hacerlo 5 metros
era fácil para mí regresé a mi casa bien
asustado dije bueno si no me voy a morir
y al desacatar a que me pasara algo
similar yo si no me voy a morir tengo
que ser con mi vida empecé a trabajar
empecé a funcionar en mi vida empecé a
ser útil a jalones trate de mantener a
mi familia mi esposa de mi hija a
jalones también y con felicidad moderada
y con trabajo y ingresos moderados pero
todavía traía algún pendiente que el
resentimiento que le traiga mis papás
hace 10 años así con ese resentimiento
acumulando lo hasta que un día me decidí
a ir a hablar con ellos me senté en la
casa de mis papás mi papá estaba
comiendo mi mamá ya estaba durmiendo una
siesta
lg papá te tengo que decir algo yo ya
estaba listo para tirarle toda mi
toxicidad y tome repudió y mi hijo dijo
nomas déjame decirte algo antes yo a ti
saleh le dije me dijo cuando tu mamá y
yo llevábamos siete años de casados y
nos dimos cuenta que no podíamos tener
un hijo biológico recibimos una llamada
de un hospital donde habían abandonado
un bebé recién nacido la familia
biológica se fue y lo dejaron en manos
de la enfermera a través de contacto
recibimos una llamada fuimos por ti a
partir de ese día somos los papás más
felices del mundo gracias hijo y yo que
le llevaba todo mi odio
no puedes servir en ese momento se fue
se fue todo mi rencor ni resentimiento
mi odio hacia ellos toda esa frustración
se fue se convirtió en dos cosas muy
bonitas que son las dos emociones más
poderosas que salvaron mi vida amor y
gratitud
cuando me dijo mi papá que yo era
adoptado me sentí como el kung fu panda'
cuando le dicen que es hijo de un ganso
este soy yo esta es mi familia mi hija
mi esposa
es muy diferente la vida después de ese
acontecimiento se integró el éxito y la
felicidad mi vida gracias a esas dos
emociones gratitud y amor
y me volvió un estudioso de por qué nos
comportamos como nos comportamos y de
qué podemos hacer para ser felices y
éxitos nos volvió un investigador y
ahora te comparto lo que para mí son
puntos muy importantes si tuvieras que
priorizar entre la felicidad y el éxito
cuál le darías prioridad
la cual bueno pues vamos por el buen
camino no sabes cuántas personas me han
dicho eso y no lo hacen entonces la
felicidad es primero tienes que
priorizar
si vas a llegar al éxito pero te voy a
dar unos consejos sobre cómo llegar al
éxito en base a mi experiencia mi
historia de vida y todo lo que estudiado
puntos a considerar encuentra tu
propósito de vida tu propósito de vida
es aquellas cosas que amas a hacer y que
las áreas de a gratis si no tuvieras que
comer aquellas cosas que te llenan y
aquellas cosas que te van a hacer mejor
persona y que te van a hacer que le
dejes algo de vuelta al mundo cuando tú
te hayas ido que le vas a dejar el mundo
ahí está tu propósito de vida y no
importa desde qué trinchera lo hagas si
lo haces atrás de una computadora en una
oficina si lo haces a través de una
herramienta en un taller mecánico no
importa el propósito de vida es
universal en donde estés te va a servir
para lo mismo sale el siguiente punto es
inteligencia emocional la inteligencia
emocional salva vidas la capacidad de
auto conocerte y de auto gestionar tus
propias emociones maximizar las
positivas minimizar las negativas tus
proyectos económicos todos tus proyectos
que tengan que ver con qué
a ganar mucho dinero alineados con tu
propósito de vida que vayan de la mano
que no se vayan jaloneando porque este
jaloneo es muy desgastante y es muy duro
te desgasta emocionalmente para eso
tienes que tener la inteligencia
emocional pero cuando logras integrar tu
propósito de vida para lo que estás aquí
y para lo que vas a dejar un mundo mejor
con tus proyectos económicos sucede algo
maravilloso es algo maravilloso se se
llama que el trabajo se convierte en una
diversión y deja de ser ese penoso
lastre detenerte que levantar todas las
mañanas todos los lunes a tener que ir a
trabajar sino que te das una marometa de
gusto y sales y lo haces con toda la
pasión del universo en vez de
arrastrarse por el edredón para apagar
el despertador
tus batallas
están aquí para algo tus retos tus
problemas el mayor problema que tenemos
los seres humanos es que creemos que no
deberíamos de tener problemas ese es el
mayor problema del ser humano los
evadimos los escribamos les sacamos la
vuelta nos la pasamos diciendo ojalá que
no me pase a mí esto hay pobres fulanita
pero lo que no sabemos es que están aquí
para hacerte mejor para hacerte crecer
para hacerte aprender y para cumplir tu
propósito de vida incluso si estás al
borde de la muerte
cuando estés enfrentando tus batallas
las batallas a veces se vuelven muy
duras muy intensas mucho dolor mucho
drama mucha crisis hay tres aliados que
son emociones poderosas que yo te quiero
compartir que las uses que las vivas que
las integren a tu vida cada vez que
puedas esos tres aliados se llaman amor
gratitud y contribución cuando las
empiezas a vivir tu vida es diferente
esas tres aliados salvan vidas entonces
el éxito a qué horas llega
pues llega solo señores el éxito llega
cuando has alineado todo lo anterior el
éxito es una consecuencia de vivir una
vida plena alineado propósito de vida
que todos tus proyectos estén alineados
hacia eso
no esperes
no esperes a estar al borde de la muerte
como lo hice yo o que una noticia
impactante cambie tu vida y te sacuda
como me pasó a mí
sacude tu a la vida con tu entusiasmo el
factor diferenciador en este mundo eres
tú nomás para tener éxito y felicidad
eres tú quienes están de acuerdo
levanten la mano y digan yo entonces con
las dos manos a sus dos compañeros de
los lados choca las bien fuerte y diles
la diferencia la hago yo que se escuche
bien fuerte
eso
soy tónicas y esta idea creo que vale la
pena compartir muchas gracias
[Aplausos]